hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about different ways in which
flagella can be arranged around
bacterial cells let's start briefly by
talking about what flagella are they are
long tail like appendages like the ones
pictured here that are used for movement
so they're used for movement otherwise
called motility and they basically
function like a propeller now in
bacteria they have a rotating motion
whereas in other types of cells like in
eukaryotes for example the flagellum
waves and kind of a whip like motion and
bacteria it rotates so it really is like
like a propeller and it can rotate in a
counterclockwise direction in order to
cause what are known as runs and it can
move in a clockwise direction to cause
what are known as tumbles and so this
results in kind of like a random type of
movement sometimes but really it is
quite directional so they can move it in
a counterclockwise direction or to make
long runs in a particular direction or
they can move it in a clockwise way to
cause them to sort of tumble around and
change direction before switching to do
a run in a different direction and these
are composed of the protein known as
flagella and bacterial cells and so now
let's talk about some of these
arrangements there's several possible
arrangements here the first one we'll
talk about is a tragus a means none that
prefix a means not an Internet the South
that does not have
any flagellum at all and then there the
next possible arrangement is mono tragus
mono means one and this is when you have
a cell with one flagellum anthat Rika's
antha means both so anthat reikus cells
are those that have a flagellum on both
and then there's also low so try guess
low fo meaning bundle or tuft
so bundle are tough from local try guess
you can see that there is a bundle or
talk of flagella at one end now remember
we have one flagellum its flagellum
ending in um for singular if we have two
or more than they call them flagella as
oral terminology and the fifth possible
arrangement is peri Trancas peri meaning
all around or surrounding and so you can
see in a peri tragus arrangement there
are flagella all around the surface of
the cell now you can occasionally see
bacteria that have a tuft on both ends
and sometimes they're called an petraeus
and sometimes they're called local
troika's there's not a great term to
mean tuft on either end but these are
the five major types of arrangements if
you're interested in learning more about
bacterial cells for example the
different kinds of shapes that they can
have them please see my video on the
different shape classifications of
bacteria if you want to learn about
their cell walls for grand positive cell
walls and gram-negative cell walls I
also have a video on that topic for you
to check out so thanks today for
watching biology professor and I hope to
see you next time bye